let's just say you and I were friends
yeah you know let's just say we could
make a go of it explain how this would
happen no no don't act see we've known
each other a long time we've both done
fine in the comedy world
uh we both cut a fine figure why
couldn't you and I hang out together how
would that work would that work in your
life if we hung out a little bit no
don't work see see we you're
good friends you need to be able to
borrow another pants I
can't wear your pants
yo your waistline too high your
waistline is up you can't
wear that I can't borrow your
I mean I can't there's nothing you can
give me that that's gonna benefit me
shoot big my
pants too goddamn long
so your friendship is all based on
whether I can wear another man's pants
you gotta be able to hang out in
someone's closet and talk to each
other and just hang out while you're
trying on pants yeah I've never
heard of a friendship described that way
hey let's go over to my house and
exchange this chance you
do this on I can't say that to you
put this on right pass me
to your knees yeah no those
would look like britches on me
like but in your search for
friendship
you have to search for yourself oh wow
and I don't think you'll look for
yourself yet one day you should get the
up right and get dressed and go the
outside your house and look for you
just look for your ass well wait a
minute I'm I'm I know where I am you're
saying I should go outside my house and
find me find your ass yeah go outside
one day and you know what here's what
you're gonna do Colin uh call the police
and report yourself missing
call the police
reports Mr O'Brien is missing a lot of
people should do that it's a lot of
people out there who lost themselves
they need to call the police
department and Report themselves missing
huh no no no no now when they
investigate you will be arrested but
you tell them I've been trying to find
myself for years and they'll understand
he said I've been lost for a long time
I've been lost and I need to do
something I need an intervention someone
had to step in here and help me find
myself and then you proceed to help the
police find you now you think the police
are going to go along with this they've
come all the way over to my house
probably there's probably a house fire
that they skipped just to come and then
I explained to them hi guys uh I'm just
having a bit of a crisis and I'm trying
to find myself you see I'm the guy that
was reported missing and I reported
myself you think that goes over well
with these cops like yeah well if these
officers have a heart a real heart and
as you explain this to them but you've
got to be compassionate don't
Snicker don't laugh
don't smile if you can force a tear out
your eye like that Indian
did don't let the commercials back in
the day
let me cry every time
cause I got it I can got it I
hate litter yeah and it touched me see I
can remember that commercial it's like I
remember but background in theorem
so you explain it the right way Conan
these are all building blocks for you
you need to explain it the right way to
them with heart with compassion I said
look man
I know you guys got a lot to do you got
to say that first yeah
yeah
I know you have a lot to do yeah you
gotta say no I know you guys got a lot
to do out there I know it's rough
outside
I've been trying to find myself for a
long time and then you say some crazy
like I don't find myself
around the air for a little while you
know just like just like this just like
this and do this right here
so it's gonna get real bad I I took a
friend and they were leaving he's in the
basement I tied him up you say you feel
me he like this yeah
you say not like this and you say give
me one minute let me shut this
up down in the basement
These Guys these cops are gonna light me
up with their tasers
I say this
but I really feel like for you to find
the right people to pull into your life
you have to find yourself
you got to find who the you are
yeah I know I know I know we are older
now but God damn it you gotta find
someone who's gonna be who able to give
you something that you're looking for
for the rest of your life
you feel me yeah and that's how life is
man you better find somebody get up on
that missing piece you gotta find
somebody Who's down to do like Naked and
Afraid with you you know no uh I've
looked around and uh nobody wants to do
Naked and Afraid with me nobody no
network wants to see that there's not a
person on Earth who wants to see naked
and afraid with Conan O'Brien no that is
a they need to make it in a free Resort
or something like that around there but
that'll be cool that'd be some cool
right there look at your favorite Resort
that'd be naked and relaxed yeah
that's pretty cool yeah would you think
you could do Naked and Afraid oh yeah I
could do it what not walk around that
like there's nothing like this is
it like you hear me I'll walk around
that Resort chilling
goddamn hat and my dick out
wait so you're yeah you still have the
Hat on you're still up you still have a
very stylish hat on and then you're
completely naked yeah if I do feel
uncomfortable I'll just laugh like y'all
crazy as hell just cover yourself up
with the old hat yeah I like it yeah why
not why not you know see you have that
why not attitude I think I'm too fearful
I mean I am uh afraid I'm a fearful
person I'm not naked I'm never naked but
never been naked in my entire life but
uh but I think I am someone who thinks
too much yeah I get in my own way my my
thoughts do get cluttered I do have a
bit of a toilet tank up there for a
brain you do you were right about
everything you've said so far in so many
ways you have to you gotta understand
what works for you and what does not
work for you once you start to eliminate
now you're now when you start to
eliminate things because you prefer a
certain a person around you so your your
your
you have a very small circle left of
what fits in there yeah yeah see you
heard somebody they say uh you're
painting something to a corner yeah yeah
you paint yourself into a corner
see okay well I don't quite see how that
falls
how did I hit myself into a corner
you go to Home Depot sometimes
you pour the thing in there you
do this and you pinch
yourself into a corner you don't
I know it that is for phrases but I
swear to God Jimmy I'm quite confident
sometimes you think of the phrase say it
with great confidence and then spend a
while justifying it you know what your
problem is you didn't shake the bottle
before you opened it that uh that meant
the dressing wasn't all mixed up that's
your
problems in the paint what's that that's
even better than the pencil you see the
oil in the bottom of that
sitting here if you don't shake this
up the oil can't mix in
with the regular stuff you're right you
absolutely